Qualcomm's Snapdragon chipset solutions enable some of the industry's...
...most powerful smartphones on the market today.
This is why, we say that inside today's smartest devices beats the heart of a dragon.
But we cannot bestow the heart of a dragon without first learning what that truly means.
Thus, Qualcomm has created the Way of the Dragon retreat,...
...so that we all may become one with the closest thing on Earth to a true dragon,...
...Komodo dragons.
These creatures know all the truth of the universe if we simply choose to listen.
Our innovative training with Komodo dragons makes Qualcomm engineers...
...more alert, more awake, more attuned to their essence.
It's an innovative approach that helps our engineers...
...develop new levels of creativity and ingenuity when faced with challenges.
Komodo dragons help us see new possibilities,...
...and I think that's reflected by the fact that Snapdragon is the best chipset on the market.
For more information, please visit facebook.com/qualcomm.